[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants vont fort
j'espère que rémi toto et fanfan font
mieux ce soir et qui n'ont plus mal aux
oreilles je descend vite les voir ce
jury tu es très courageux nounours mais
attention de ne pas attraper les
oreillons toi aussi au pas de risque
patron je les ai déjà une europe où le
jeune papa ben tant mieux ils ont encore
faim invite à remplir d'autres
bonjour bonsoir à tous je viens m'aider
à porter les vivres aux sons pour pu
tous et non pour des besoins de ses
appétits tiens prends ces deux là
attention c'est chaud oui ils sont
chauds
alors ces petits anges pour soir ils ont
l'air d'aller très bien oui à la des
familles pourront bientôt
[Musique]
ils n'ont plus de fièvre ils sont
presque guérie qui était rallye qui
pourrait signer veine du moment thème 1
eh bien demain on fera un bon jeu tous
ensemble d'accords les enfants aujourd
hui à la dino ours du zoo
le dr il a dit qu'on aurait peut-être
nous aussi les ohayon tralala moi j'ai
eu un contact
j'ai déjà eu la rougeole mais moi je
suis très content parce que j'ai pas eu
la rougeole et que j'avance les arts
ayant ne fait pas trop de bruit
le som mes neveux s'endormir avec leurs
biberons bien nicolas sachy
oh
[Musique]
o o
oh
dimanche tu viendras me raconter des
histoires quand j'aurai les oreillons
petit nico tu n'as pas encore les
oreillons et ce n'est pas sûr que tu les
as tu raques jamais été malade sinon ce
petit garnement d'orbites et toi aussi
pape rebelles là geithner
quant au made man tu n'as rappaz les
oreilles au nicolas j'aurai les
oreillons tap runner
[Musique]
soir les enfants en dormez vous vite et
si vous avez les oreillons prenez bien
sagement vos médicaments
patron je m'allonge horreur gros farceur
de nounours je ne te crois pas alors en
août
bonne nuit les enfants
faites de beaux rêves
à demain à deux pas fait pour elle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]